what up space fam Golson here from anime
outpro and we got some big reveals from
Oda himself in the latest SBS he reveals
Zorro's entire family tree and so we'll
be covering everything we know about
zoro's confirmed ancestors and in what
way they are related and there are
potentially some shocking things to
discuss so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these one piece
videos you want to keep them coming
Channel parking with it and smash that
like button until you see fireworks if
you haven't made this the video you
joined the Knock Em Up by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all we find out
that that guy we saw in the wano
flashbacks who looks exactly like Zorro
named shimotsuki ushimaru the former
daimyo of Ringo was the younger brother
of zoro's Grandmother shimotsuki furico
furthermore Oda writes that shimotsuki
ushimaru is the descendant of shimotsuki
ryuma the Samurai of legend of the wano
country who Zorro met in Thriller bark
we're told Zorro isn't aware of this but
it goes showed that many of us were
right to assume that shimotsuki ushimaru
was related to Zoro despite the fact
that they didn't share a last name
anyways back to the SPs and shimotsky
furico zoro's grandmother ended up
marrying a man called roronoa pinzoro a
swordsman from shimotsky Village if I
look up the definition of pinzuro it
means double ones or in other words
Snake Eyes when it comes to the game of
dice now Snake Eyes makes me think of
Hawkeyes which may not be a big
coincidence in and of itself but when we
look at the sun the two of them had
Zorro's dad rora Noah arashi I gotta say
his silhouette also reminds me of mihawk
especially if you look at some younger
images of mihawk where he pulls the hair
back from the front but it can get
pretty wild in the back not to mention
at the back of arashi's hair is so crazy
that it sort of gives a vampire cape
look and as we know Dracula mihawk is a
reference to the most famous vampire
Dracula I'm not saying that arashi is
mihawk or anything but as with Zorro
being related to shimotsky through his
grandma I wouldn't be surprised if there
is some ancestral connection between
mihawk and rora Noah pinzoro and thus
between Zoro and mihawk 2. I never
thought about this before but with the
SPs and the Silhouettes I feel like it
could be possible in the SBS Oda says
that Zoro isn't aware of this very very
strange fate tale and what's more faded
to be than the genes of the shimotsky
and the Draculas combining to create the
future greatest Swordsmen in the world
so it's just a theory and Anime Theory
but something to consider with these
latest reveals we know Oda has nothing
against hyping up the lineage of his
characters and so it wouldn't be
anything new anyways arashi which means
storm in Japanese died in a battle
against Pirates his wife was Tara the
daughter of thieving Bandits Tara means
Earth in several languages and she died
of illness together they had Zorro and
this explains why we never saw zoro's
parents before because they were both
dead unfortunately it's notable that
arashi was also associated with pirates
as mihawk is and if we want to get
really crazy easy with it for fun mihawk
is old enough to be Zorro's dad at 43
years old he would have been 22 when
Zoro was born maybe he didn't end up
getting killed in a pirate battle but
dropped his former identity made it look
like that and became a pirate The Dread
pirate Robert style keep in mind rora
Noah comes from the French pirate
Francois Lola NOAA and mihawk definitely
seems European to me so even like I said
if we don't go with the more far-fetched
I am your father's Oro approach I feel
like we can't dismiss a connection
between the two outright it's also
emphasized in the SBS how the blades
crafted by shimotsuki kozaburo namely
wado ichimonji and enma made it back to
a descendant of the shimotsky namely
Zorro which seems more fitting or fated
to be than anyone could have guessed now
since we finally know how shimotsuki
ushimaru and ryuma are related to Zorro
let's take a closer look at them since
they can now shed more light on our
favorite swordsman and of course his
potential so shimotsuki
Uma was a legendary and world famous
Samurai he was given the almost too cool
title of Sword God and even slayed a
dragon like Zorro became eventually
ryuma was a one-eyed swordsman another
seemingly fate-related detail and he
used one sword notably Oda has actually
said that this Ruma is the same one as
his character from his One-Shot
Monster's manga in the mangas revealed
that Ruma looked very similar to Zorro
just with darker hair in that manga the
people he saves refer to Ruma as The
King and I really like this part because
a myth about the great swordsman King
who is supposed to be the strongest in
the world has spread Ruma hears it and
says he would like to fight him one day
this King not knowing that he is the
king himself he's already the strongest
in the world so clearly being associated
to this man Hypes of zoro's potential
when Zoro fought through a zombie Brooke
mentioned that the Samurai Zombie is
moving right now with his shadow but
when he was alive he must have been a
powerful fighter he says and I quote it
just may be that those two meetings are
in are the same kinds of Swordsmen with
the same kind of power end quote looking
back that's high praise for Zorro and
the clue for the eventual reveal that
they are related down the line after an
intense battles or Obe beats the Samurai
Zombie but knows that he was much more
impressive in his prime and wished he
could have seen the samurai in his prime
he even decides not to count the victory
saying let's pretend this fight never
happened then there is ushimaru the
descendant of ryuma and the brother of
Zorro's Grandma AKA zoro's great uncle
once again we have a character who looks
like Zorro except this one has blue hair
rather than black or green eventually
ushimaru too has one eye covered by
bandages in the manga so this seems to
be an ongoing similarity between them he
is the man who told a young Yamato to
call him so and so he has been described
as a master of the sword who always
traveled with his Fox companion he was
eventually imprisoned by kaido like
Zorro he is stoic in the face of
adversity and Yamato was impressed by
how he did not seem to get hungry he
could easily cut through chains is by
infusing hotkey into a sword with two
swords one in each hand we see him
easily cut through a giant boulder he
and the two other Samurai decide they'd
rather fight to the end rather than
waste away in prison we don't actually
see what happens to them but the
implication is that they lost the kaido
and his forces and lost their lives
finally there's the third Zorro who
wields not one like ryuma not two like
ushimaru but three sword which seems
fitting since he's the third and related
to mihawk or not pennzoro Zorro's
grandfather was also a swordsman so Zoro
has Swordsmen on both sides of the
family coming together to birth the
eventual strongest swordsman in the
world they also say the third time is
the charm so Zorro definitely has a lot
going for him in terms of narrative and
fate as Oda pointed out zoro's family
tree also shows how shimotsuki kozaburo
had koshiro Zoro Sensei with a girl from
the village then koshiro with a
mysteriously undescribed and unnamed
woman had Arena zoro's childhood friend
and rival who died in an accident that
we got to know very well it's not shown
where these two branches of the
shimotsky connect but it's implied that
they are all related thinking back on
the beginning of the series it's crazy
that we knew none of this when we were
first exposed to zoro's backstory or
that when Zoro talked to kozaburo that
he was related to him and Zoro was
arguably like a grandson to him that's
one of my favorite things as we learn
more about the backstories how they all
seem to shed new light on everything we
know so far and painted in a new light
but now as we wait for more greatness
from Oda channel the greatest swordsman
within and smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video until you see the
fireworks of wano and join the nakum if
you haven't already by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates let
me know your thoughts on all of this do
you like that Zoro has such legendary
relatives and do you think it's possible
that he shares one with even mihawk
making one side of his swordsman family
just as impressive as the other and if
you want to learn more about mihawk
zoro's potential other side of the fan
family you don't want to miss are all
Warlords and their powers explained
video link on screen right now and in
the description where we go into what
you need to know about mihawk the
current greatest swordsman in the world